there are growing claims that a supposed
war on Christianity is being fought at
the moment in universities in the u.s.
in one incident a student at Northeast
Wisconsin Technical College what stopped
from handing out cards containing the
word words Jesus loves you she sued
claiming her freedom of speech had been
violated but a court then threw out the
claim siding with the college which
argued she was stopped because she was
in a staff only area well in another
incident a Christian student rep at
Berkeley University is facing course to
resign after she abstained from a vote
on a resolution supporting the LGBT
community and librarians at Simmons
College published a guide warning
Christians that the phrase is Merry
Christmas have yeast and also God bless
you
our so-called micro aggressions against
Muslims we discussed the issue with
legal analyst Lionel and editor Dave
Lindell if there were any other religion
any other situation nobody would have
any problem with this none that would be
it would be up understood that it would
be it would be tolerated there would be
diversity it would be understood but if
it's Christianity if it's Jesus on
college campuses today no go there this
is open season in this country
especially on college campuses you can
go through the litany of complaints
regarding Christianity
now I'm not speaking of behalf of
somebody who was overtly Christian
I personally am irreligious does it
matter one way or the other what I'm
telling was that there it is anathema it
is considered not in any way tolerate
able it is not a diverse atheists
agnostics no problem
we understand we tolerate we get it
Christians you're on your own that's a
fact and that's just really not true I
mean I my wife teaches at Temple
University in Philadelphia and there are
Christians all over the campus handing
stuff out all the time no problem
there's bigger problems I think with
with Muslims because there's some
harassment of them
by other students but you know in
general I think in general it's
live-and-let-live with religious theft
on campuses it's a huge exaggeration and
I and and it's it's being used to
promote this notion that everybody is
becoming intolerant
you